head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard charts here we go we
got the story from the New York Post
Jill Biden's bizarre Hunger Games
aesthetic White House Christmas video
roasted by critics uh you know the first
thing I said earlier today was like you
know I don't care if they want to do
some cringe tap dancing thing but
apparently a lot of people are like yo
this is one of the worst things we've
ever seen and for that you will all now
have to watch it along with
us it's really bad it's really H do I
have to I have to unmute
it it is really really bad and this is
physically in the White House in the
White House I believe it is yeah it
looks like The Shining like you expect
the kids from The Shining to pop up out
of here candy cane walls are a little
much hey very diverse okay okay say that
again yeah look at that look how she
stares oh yeah it's like they're doing
stage acting but they're doing it on
camera that's why it looks so weird this
is what all the all the victims of MK
Ultra C before they're hijacked and
taken over and brought to the CIA secret
black sites in order to commit their
assassinations on political leaders this
is the brainwashing campaign talented
dancers but this is like what you look
at from 100 30 300 F feet away so that's
why their their faces are so I I'm sorry
I I got to be honest I I hate tat
dancing I absolutely despise tap dancing
why though it just it's like nails on a
chalkboard right that that's that's it
like nails on a chalkboard that's what
that sounds like to me I tap danc when I
was younger so I like it but I didn't
like that definitely I think just the
only thing miss him was like Dylan
mulany like he should have been in there
I mean like y I'm not going to rag on
people for wanting to do a tap dancing
Christmas that doesn't matter to me but
then I saw this this is from The Daily
Mail Joe Biden's White House Christmas
dance troop are radical BLM loving
activists who have demanded prison
abolition and defunding the police but
it's not just that people are calling it
a racist hate group a large portion of
their background is ragging on People
based on race and so the White House
decided to bring in a group to dance
around smiling when they're like
explicitly saying on their website they
hate you based on your race like that
that was kind of wild to me and that I
think is worthy of more criticism now
you add these two things together and
you get a trashy performance I don't
care for but you're allowed to like it I
don't you know if people on the left
want to like it fine whatever but
they're just a bunch of racists I don't
like racists Hunter Biden liked it after
smoking someck like substances but that
guy likes a lot of different weird stuff
so uh definitely a lot of things
reminiscing of of Hunger Games here that
a lot of people are making a lot of
comparisons to absolutely but the
organization does a lot of weird stuff
they they they I I think they're more of
an activist organization than a dance
organization they're kind of a
collective organization of radical
feminists of color they call for prison
abolition they call for defunding the
police they tell people to join their
local black lives matter chapter and
more importantly they say hey if you're
white you got to check your privilege
and you got to learn how to be mindful
and financially support other people
because you were born the wrong skin
color and therefore you are a bad person
that's extensively what they are saying
they they say that if you take issue
with being insulted based on your race
you are
fragile and so I see things like that
and I'm just like dude
there was that um that little kid who
was wearing the the the face paint for
the chief's game and he had black on one
side and red on the other and it was a a
black reporter who complained about uh
blackface and I said that's black
fragility that's what black fragility is
he he sees a kid wearing Chief's face
paint and he loses his mind and calls it
all racism and I'm like you see why you
you shouldn't do that I'm not going to
go and blame all black people because
one yelled at a kid but that's
what people like this do they say that
if you're a white person who doesn't
like being insulted based on the color
of your skin you have white fragility
and I'm like well like one white person
was upset about it I don't I don't know
that every single white person gets mad
when you criticize a white person that
black reporter who wanted to get that
kid in trouble for whatever reason he's
one guy he doesn't represent all black
people I'm s I'm like it makes no sense
to make black the focus of it the same
way they make white the focus of it this
is my problem with leftist identitarians
and being brought into the White House I
think it's disgusting they don't get
angry they get perturbed okay it's just
so hypocritical like the it's like the
Reverse Racism stuff that's happening
you know I'm half Chinese and half
Italian I don't really think about that
much but I just I feel kind of bad for
white guys in the present day like I
just feel like they are really under
attack in many ways and white women like
when the whole Karen thing I feel like
it's a very racist term to call somebody
a Caren to call White it's become a
racist term yeah but you know Reverse
Racism would be a good thing the idea
that you get a bunch of racists like
this and you reverse what they've done
but what they're actually is just
racists
right the left uses this language game
they call it Reverse Racism when they
attack white people because they want to
make it seem like they're not being
racist when like quite literally that's
all they're doing hating People based on
their race yeah the the antidote to
racism is seeing people as humans right
you know it's got worse gotten worse and
I think progressively like I think
there's more racism now than there was
20 years ago like the early 2000s say
the way I remember it I don't remember
even ever thinking about race and now
all of a sudden it's the only thing that
we're fixated on what's your race what
your sexual identity like these things
weren't things I spoke about when I was
in my late teens and early 20s a lot of
people blame Obama I I liked him in the
early days I was like he's a cool guy
and I didn't really care what he looked
like I was just listening to him and
looking into his eyes and like but then
he I guess like he would say things
about race and like and bring it up and
kind of create a polarization let's
watch this one here you
[Music]
go this is the first lady melania's
Christmas video
it is remarkably
neutral it's very white though that's
problematic those trees are too white
one lady she's white they said I'm
talking about the trees white light they
said that the white lights on the trees
were symbolic of like you know white
supremacy no lights of color right so so
in this video a lot of people are
comparing the two videos are saying
Melania was better we don't we don't
need to hear from Peter Ducey right now
they're saying melania's was better
because hers was just a very neutral
this is the White House on Christmas I
got to say I'd call it lowest common
denominator meaning it wasn't really
much of anything everybody got to see
the White House it was Christmas time
how how nice right I actually hey look I
think it's great that the the White
House celebrated Christmas I think the
way they celebrated was kind of tacky
but it's fine not everybody has to like
what I like and I don't have to like
what you like but don't bring a bunch of
racists in to do it pisses me off I got
a little Disturbed at them I mean it's
like it is the White House and it is the
capital and like but they decked it out
with a lot of like gudy like furniture
and trees and decorations and like
people are I don't want to speak for
everyone but a lot of people I think the
economy is like I going to point that
out like there's so many people
suffering and they're putting tap
dancing on America's casket essentially
they're tap dancing and everyone's being
financially ruined but this is why
they're calling it Hunger Games yeah no
absolutely sorry car I cut you off no it
was okay I was just going to say that
you know it just it is a smack in the
face I think to a lot of people in
America who especially in the lower
classes who really are suffering from
the economy and I didn't like I don't
consider myself lower income I'm right
in the middle so I think the people in
the lower income communities feel it the
most cuz I go out and talk to people all
the time for my job reporting for
Newsmax and Gateway pundit and you know
it's it's a real thing like people
literally living paycheck to paycheck
like they spend their last $10 on that
day's lunch so I think to put a video
like that up and like use people of
color as always as tokens um is is
offensive to people that are literally
starving and don't have money for food
and then they're putting up these like
tap dancers tap dancing around the White
House with like candy canes and these
crazy glitzy gudy decorations especially
with all the resources now going to
Illegal immigration and helping them out
as there are a lot of Mainline stories
of a lot of communities specifically
poor communities being denied resources
that they had before that are now being
diverted to of course the new Democratic
voting base that is literally being
shipped into this country right but
they're they're they're really out of
touch I think that that's a pandering
move what they did there it's like
they're pandering to for like the
diversity and inclusion stuff I don't
even think people like minorities are
really into that like they just want to
be able to pay their bills and the
economy to approve they're not impressed
with that especially people that I talk
to you know but it's not but but here's
the thing it's not for them right Jill
Biden didn't produce this video for poor
people she produced it for her peers you
know when I worked at Vice we were uh uh
constantly talking about content to make
and what the strategy was and I was
always just wondering why it was that
the higher-ups of the company were so
focused on cable television I was like
who cares and I understand it's
guaranteed contract money it's like you
sign a 10-year deal for a terrestrial
cable and you get guaranteed Revenue
coming in through the cable
subscriptions and all that stuff that I
understood but I was like that's not
going to build your brand up and then I
realized it rather
quickly Shane Smith and the other people
who were higher ups were in their mid
40s mid to late 40s their whole world
was being on TV they did not grow up
with the internet the way we did and so
as the younger guys in our 20s were
looking at how to get online and
maximize viewership he was chasing the
Caboose of the trend that had already
left the station exactly what I thought
out of touch that was the exact right
words that went through my mind when
when I saw this first I was like Jill
and Joe are so out of touch with what's
going on exactly Joe Biden is not
thinking about poor people in this
country she's going I wonder what people
would like what does people mean people
means the 1% It means the people who
make 600 plus thousand a year and she's
like o they'll really like this you know
there's some kind of sociopathic PR guy
at the White House who's like we're
losing the black vote we're losing the
election we're not doing that well I got
an idea let's get black people smiling
and dancing that's going to show
everyone that they're really happy right
guys and like yeah yeah sure Bob yeah
sure and then they do this and and then
it's like what what the crap what the
freaking hell is this bull crap it
almost what is that that old stuff that
they used to do and they would have like
people in Black La tap dancing it was
that old school form of entertainment it
kind of REM reminds me of that yeah they
could have toned it down for camera at
least like the whole like right like
that stuff keep that for the stage yeah
yeah yeah it's a little yeah gy a lot I
like that's the way you described it I
think so but again you know I want to
stress this I think a lot of people are
ragging on the performance and I'm just
like uh that comes off as so partisan
like oh I just don't like the way
they're dressed and they're tap dancing
and I'm like well I mean I don't like it
either but I don't care I mean but if we
want to make an argument about what the
White House should be and decorum and
all that stuff that I get that I get
that's more what it's about cuz they
were I thought they were doing a great
job dancing just hands down I didn't
want to just insult it for the sake of
insulting it they're good dancers and it
was actually mouth movements like what
the hell are you doing but that's that's
that's what it is that's the traditional
like style like like you was saying it's
like stage work but they're doing it on
camera it's weird oh so minstral shows
was what you were talking about minstral
shows right when they're when they sort
of like subjugate minorities and black
people to dancing and tap dancing on
stage that's what that reminded me of a
minstral show I it just looks it just
looks kind of weird and then when if you
look at Art architecture movies uh
models and and everything else in our
society if if it's woke it's it's kind
of trash and and I think that's that's
not an accident I think this is meant to
beat down the human spirit I think this
is an attack on beauty because once you
attack that you attack the human spirit
and human will to kind of live and
survive you look around the Democratic
areas there's not a lot of energy that
is good there there's not a lot of
spirit there's not a lot of growth
there's not a lot of potential it's all
regressive it's all low vibrational and
I don't think that's an accident I think
this ugliness is being thrown on us
deliberately in many different ways all
around us culturally because what better
way way to subjugate and destroy a
population than to make it ugly I would
have loved just a video of Jill and Joe
sitting by a tree lighting a candle and
then saying or it's saying we're all in
this together even though there's crap
going on in the world just something
simple and unifying would have been nice
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at
timcast.net thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time